vraiment sympa super aimable super
gentil la polémique qui a eu comme quoi
il aurait fait sortir les enfants
musulmans
mon fils m'a dit que ce n'était pas
juste pour les préserver c'était plus
petit et par pure gentillesse quoi parce
qu'il devait montrer une caricature du
prophète de l'islam
il a tout simplement dit à vos enfants
ou d'enfants musulmans sortent et j'ai
pas envie que ça vous fasse mal au coeur
ce que mon fils m'a dit
ils sont sortis tu vois là quand il a
fait sortir les enfants n'étaient pas
pour rester pas pour discriminer quitté
qui que ce soit ou quoi que ce soit
comme ça c'était vraiment pour lui c'est
vraiment pour les préserver ce que la
sphère c'était réglé je crois deux ou
trois jours après il avait ramené
quelqu'un de l'éducation nationale
quelques parents étaient venus ils
étaient tous unanimes pour dire c'est un
homme qui a fait une erreur c'est tout
apparemment les réseaux sociaux avait
fait que s'envenimer les chaussants pas